new theory in which a faceless man
assassin was highly paid for his
services which in this case would be
helping littlefinger to avoid certain
death
this theory is supported with quite a
few clues and proofs so let's get right
into it peter baelish the most cunning
unpredictable and ruthless manipulator
of court politics falls to his knees and
begs for his life upon realizing his zen
is sealed a few moments later arya slits
his throat with the same dagger that was
given to the catspaw assassin to kill
bran
peter collapses to the floor and dies in
the pool of his own blood many fans were
disappointed with that scene because
even though we all wanted to see baelish
die it felt like a cheap death scene
it definitely was not good enough for
the greatest villain of game of thrones
that littlefinger certainly was
now don't get me wrong it's not about
who set him a trap and executed him i'm
perfectly fine with that
it took the lady of winterfell the
three-eyed raven and the skill assassin
to finally put an end to peter baelish
however it's entire game of thrones show
but mostly season 7 scenes that are not
going hand to hand with lilyfinger's
death
let's firstly take a look on this scene
sometimes
when i try to understand a person's
motives
i play a little game
i assume the worst
what's the worst reason they could
possibly have for
saying what they say and doing what they
do
then i ask myself how well does that
reason
explain what they say
and what they do now let's get a bit
back in the season where littlefinger
met with bran stark and gave him the
valyrian steel dagger
during their conversation peter pointed
out to bran how impressive it is that he
managed to survive be on the wall only
to return to such chaos on which brain
replied with chaos is a ladder
[Music]
this is the very same thing littlefinger
told to wear is during his rise in power
after following joffrey baratheon to
kill ross
chaos isn't a pit
is a ladder slightly unnerved baelish
then exits upon the interests of mira
reed addressing bran as lord stark
however bran corrected littlefinger
explaining that he cannot be a lord
because he is now the three-eyed raven
after this meeting littlefinger most
certainly
played his little game that he mentioned
to sensa he asked himself was the worst
reason brandt could possibly have to say
what he said
the lillyfinger as he said himself
assumes the worst which would in this
case for bailey's obviously be that bran
truly is the three-eyed raven and can in
fact see the events that occurred in the
past
meaning that littlefinger should have
been aware that bran can see the past
and therefore if bran was able to go
back in the past and witness a small
talk between varys and him
bran most certainly also witnessed his
betrayal over ned stark then we also
have this scene in which littlefinger
watches zarya as she sparse with brienne
the important detail here is that
lucario gives peter after the practice
arya looks up at peter with disapproving
and untrustworthy look
[Music]
hatching another cunning plan peter
bounced from the high volts and walks
away from mario's view
so once again littlefinger plays his
little game what's the worst reason arya
could possibly have for looking up at
him with an untrustworthy look
littlefinger knew wario was timely
lannister scott bearer at the time he
paid visit to timing at harrenhal
littlefinger was aware that harry
overheard their conversation regarding a
plan of defeating the starks
then he asks himself was the worst thing
gary could want the answer is obvious
arya wants him dead playing his own game
littlefinger should have known his life
was in great danger
littlefinger should have left as soon as
brent quoted him as by that time he
should have realized that bran probably
witnessed his betrayal over ned stark
among all other crimes of his against
house stark bailly should have been
aware that it's only the matter of time
van bram will reveal it to his sister
sansa but also to his sister arya who
happens to be a former faceless man
assassin and the person able to kill
anyone at any time however in this
theory supported by the fact that
littlefinger plays his mentioned little
game baelish was aware that his end is
sealed however just before he left
winterfell he tried one more thing
after trying and failing to manipulate
the stark children peter forged a plan
to separate the stark's sisters
littlefinger allowed arya to spy on him
so she could find a copy of sansa's
letter to rob hoping that it will turn
the hot temper darya against her sister
even though arya did confront sansa just
like he wanted and even though sensa did
become worried that tarya could turn the
northerners against her
or even worse at the end sensa did
something bailish did not expect from
her
after littlefinger implanted the idea
that arya has come home only to kill her
and become lady of winterfell
sansan cheryl peter's intentions visited
bran to seek for help
from this sensa learned of his green
side powers in which he proved silly
fingers ultimate guilt in the war of the
five kings however due to all his spies
in winterfell littlefinger learned that
the stark's sisters sowed through his
plan and were even making their own plan
to have him executed this clip from
episode 5 of season 7 confirms it
if you listen carefully you can hear
saying your time is up
let me roll the clip again but this time
with increased volume
[Music]
this is a moment littlefinger realized
his plans failed so the only choice for
him was to leave winterfell before he
gets executed and he did
i know that you're wondering how is it
possible that lillyfinger left
winterfell in the fifth episode of the
season when he appeared and was in fact
killed in the final episode of the
season
well in this theory it was not peter
bailey she was executed in the great
hall of winterfell but rather a faceless
man wearing littlefinger's face
i know that most of you have already
rejected this theory mostly because
quite a bit amount of you don't believe
that the faceless man can wear a face of
someone that is alive cannot create a
face in order to portray someone else
but you might be wrong
there's a scene that took place in the
final episode of season 5 in jacking gar
warrior's face who was standing just
beside him
but if you're
who's this no one at all
just as a girl should have been before
she took a face from the hall
your faces are for no one
you are still someone
and to someone the faces are as good as
poison
[Music]
this scene might be confirming that the
faceless man assassins can wear a face
of a person that is not dead of a person
that is still alive since they might be
able to create a mask from other faces
to look just like the face of the person
they want to portray
during the game of thrones series
slowfinger threw the seven kingdoms into
the state of chaos from which he
personally benefited and grew rather
wealthy
it said that for a good price a cult of
religious assassins that worship the
many faced god will grant the gift of
death to anyone in the world
so it's possible that they would for a
good price suffer their own life for the
many-faced god which one of them by this
theory did
could it be the little finger instead of
giving money to his spy for her
information which we all assumed he did
could it be that he actually gave the
bravo siren coin to a faceless man
assassin who then played role of
littlefinger let's not forget that
littlefinger descends from a bravo c
sellsword and therefore it's definitely
not out of the realm of possibilities
that littlefinger could have had a
connection with the faceless men who are
based in the free city of braavos
there's even one scene from the very
first season in which littlefinger
basically confirmed that he has some
friends in
essos of course you would have friends
from across the narrow sea
you're from there yourself after all if
baelish finds it common for someone to
have powerful friends across the narrow
sieve that someone descends from there
then he himself must have had some
friends in essos as well since he
descends from there too
let me know if you think that arguably
the most cunning and the most
intelligent player in game of thrones
series bailly should ignore his own
little game that he placed and got
himself killed
or do you on the other hand think that
all those clothes and proofs are
actually confirming otherwise that he
faked his own death and is alive and
well
could it be that little finger truly did
make a mistake and got himself killed
definitely after all despite his
ingenious planning and manipulation
billish is not incapable of making
mistakes
he made a few mistakes that almost got
him killed earlier in the show
the first one was when he subtly made a
jab at cersei about her relationship
with her brother jaime that knowledge is
power
this resulted its cersei nearly having
him killed before deciding to remind him
of his
place proving that power is far more
important than knowledge bailly shows to
remark to wearers that tirion is an
unworthy ally seemingly underestimated
ramsey bolton's vile nature wrongly
believed that the north would not rally
behind jon snow
littlefinger believed that the northern
lords would rally behind sansa stark
which would have made her the queen in
the north
rather than raleigh behind as he said
himself matterless bastard born in the
south
littlefinger was also initially
skeptical of bran stark's powers as the
new three-eyed raven
long story short peter baelish is not
incapable of making mistakes
and therefore unless this theory that i
introduced you with in this video proves
to be true baelish's mistakes led him to
his death
littlefinger has orchestrated many of
the most monumental events in game of
thrones
this list includes ned stark's downfall
the stark lannister conflict and
joffrey's homicide while i've also made
a theory in which lil finger caused
robert's rebellion as well
some people used to describe peter
baelish as one of the most dangerous men
in the seven kingdoms
now let me say it again i was so
impatient to see littlefinger being
brought to justice by stark's sisters
with the help of the all-seeing brother
bran but it's all the scenes that are
not going hand to hand with his death
these scenes have not only provided a
proof that baelish knew their intentions
from the very start but some could even
be considered as a proof that
littlefinger has left winterfell as soon
as his spies found out that his time was
up
littlefinger's death scene was so
dramatic and completely out of his
character that i could actually see it
being someone else who is trying to act
like him
i cannot claim that those numerous clues
are confirming that littlefinger faith
is death and is alive but your time is
up scene and every other scene that i
provided you in this video are certainly
interesting and without the question
deserves some speculation and